so Hollywood I've been seeing how you
handling the strikes and
uh I got a few
[Music]
notes hey folks some more thoughts on
the strikes I said I would follow up off
of last Saturday's video talking about
some of the ways that the studios and
Executives have badly miscalculated this
one and I think these are contributing
factors to why they're going to lose now
there is a main thing that I'm going to
be focusing on and while that is not the
main reason I believe the studios are
going to lose it uh is a major
contributing factor that I don't see
brought up all that often at least not
directly and properly acknowledg at
least I don't think so um but as I said
what I'm going to be focusing on which
we'll get to is not the main reason that
I think the studios are going to be the
ones to cave on this there are uh quite
a few stemming from initially the fact
that the studios a lot of them are not
in great positions right now a lot of
them sunk a ton of money to streaming
services that most of which are not
profitable on their own and hence
they're having to jack up the prices
remove stuff in some cases effectively
remove things permanently if it was
truly unique and made for that platform
and isn't being sold or rented out to
somebody else to be able to stream
elsewhere the cracks are showing in the
models that they've been doing there has
been a downturn at the box office for
most of these Studios a lot of stuff
that should have been runaway hits have
not been a lot of things for from
reliable franchises that like that's
obviously that's at least a half billion
dollar take it the box office and they
either haven't gotten there or they've
struggled this has not been a great year
for the studios which which is a very
good time to strike as much as people
like Bob Iger will complain about how uh
inconvenient the timing is no the timing
is actually uh very convenient you don't
take on an opponent when they are at
their strongest Bob besides which the
issues that were happening with both the
writers and the actors contracts uh
they're relevant right now whether
you're in a position of power or not cuz
keep in mind the timing of the strikes
was not done deliberately because the
studio are having an off year the timing
of the strikes was because old contracts
were up and contract negotiations broke
down if they were going to happen they
were going to happen now no matter what
it just happened to be the studios were
not in a great position and that matters
because how long the shareholders will
put up with the studios refusing to
return to the negotiating
table it's hard to calculate how long
that'll be it ain't forever it's not
infinite because the actors and the
writers can quantify what they're asking
for and what it will cost and if Studios
hold out too long especially at this
point with how much the investors are
driving the decisions that Studios and
executives are
making yeah when the losses from delayed
or canceled projects or just failing to
be able to put as much stuff out in a
year because you have to take what
little finished stuff you have and
stretch it out over a longer period of
time because you're not making new stuff
it's not going to take all that long in
the grand scheme of things for the uh
impact on your bottom line to exceed
what it would cost you to just give them
what they're asking
for now this is all Hollywood of course
which means Hollywood accounting which
means if they want to make it look like
it's not costing them as much as it
probably is they can and they will but
that's kicking the can down the road you
can't pretend that everything's fine
forever especially with how long this
has already gone G on and is continuing
to go on now all of that is already in
play there's also additional factors
like the issue that a lot of things that
the unions are stuck on are issues of uh
ai ai in writer rooms AI uh scans of
actors used to create background
performances the thing is um there have
been a number of court cases including
some quite recent ones that have
reaffirmed the idea that AI content is
not copyrightable
now that in and of itself won't stop the
studios I'm pretty sure that uh their
plan especially with something like say
writers was to have an AI generate the
rough script and then bring in a script
writer to polish it up and finish it and
they can claim well a human touch that
that is copyrightable um that whether or
not that would actually hold up hard to
know but it's not a simple case of well
AI generated this it's ours now well no
courts are repeatedly that is not
material that can get a copyright and
the reason I bring that up is just
because as these sorts of court cases
happens as these things come up it's
just going to be more evidence that what
the studios are fighting to be able to
do might not even be worth doing in the
first place and that's not even getting
to the artistic issues of whether or not
it's uh worth for the benefit of the
state-ofthe-art to be doing it which
it's not but even the raw financials
might not add up so I do think that the
studios are going to lose but the I want
to focus on here is something that I
think legitimately really blindsided
them really caught them off guard and
they should have known better they
didn't very clearly uh the thing
is by and large when the studios were
trying to figure out do we want to hold
out and do we want to put our feet down
about this do we want to give any ground
do we want to give a little how do we
want to work this they were probably
largely looking at the last last few
times that strikes have happened now the
actors haven't struck in quite a while
the last writer strike was back in 2007
into
2008 the thing is while that is still
within living memory and within memory
of probably a decent percentage of the
executive class of the
studios a lot has changed since then you
know what I think the studios didn't
count on and did not factor into their
calculations at
all social media
now to be fair back in 2007 2008 when
the uh last writer strike happened the
concept of going viral was a thing it
did exist but it tended to
be very hard to predict very
uncontrollable it's not something you
could just do and not all that many
creative figures felt very
accessible but you know what's happened
since
2007 Instagram has gotten big Tik Tok
Twitter uh some uh creators behind the
scenes have embraced
YouTube they have a means of accessing
the public and influencing public
opinion now you might find yourself
wondering why does public opinion matter
it's not like this is being voted on by
the general public well public opinion
matters because if the winds are
swinging in the direction of one side or
the other that is going to impact
negotiations a classic part of the
tactic for entities these Studios um
when the strike goes on is as things
start to become inconvenient and the
effects trickle down and become more
noticeable not only to their investors
but the public at large that consumes
the product that they make they want to
be able to blame the strikers and say
it's their fault that you are not
getting new episodes of your favorite
shows it's their fault that we can't
confirm a new season for this show it's
their fault that we can't send out any
uh people to do promotion for for this
movie it's their fault that this movie
shut down etc etc and the thing
is that is just a perspective and it's
theirs but it's a lot easier to sell
when you have tighter control of the
narrative and the way more people were
getting their news on things like
strikes on the last strike and certainly
in the times before if they cared at all
they were getting it from News Net Works
writeups in
newspapers and those have a tendency to
f
corporate entities just inherently but
just to take for example if uh a
representative of the unions and a
representative of the studios were to
like do a little talking head segment on
a cable news show you'd hear from both
you'd hear from one you hear from the
other it's fairly even playing field on
paper one doesn't get to have an
advantage or you know you can
potentially if you have uh a studio that
also owns networks or uh that run on
news or news networks you could possibly
even put your thumb on the scale a
little bit I don't want to accuse anyone
of doing that but it's certainly a thing
that you could viably do in terms of how
coverage tilts who you talk to more do
you give the actors a platform or are
you giving Studio heads a platform the
uh people that you tend to bring in your
local experts on this stuff that you
tend to bring in for these sorts of
things maybe you're not giving a voice
to either the executives or the actors
but what leaning does your uh inhouse
entertainment journalist have
that's a narrative that's easier to
control you know what's real hard to
control when both actors and writers
have access to massive followings on
Twitter Instagram Tik Tok YouTube and
even if they don't have massive
followings they have friends who do have
massive followings and they can borrow
those
platforms this is why Adam Conover keeps
going viral over and over again this is
why Neil gaimon has been seen on the
picket line in videos this is why that
that video of Ron Pearlman pretty
directly threatening Executives be
careful mother be really careful there's
a reason people saw that they would not
have seen that in 2007 and they
definitely wouldn't have seen it in any
strike
before the public is now accessible
without the
gatekeeping of approved news sources
like new newspapers magazines cable
networks or Nightly
News those things are a lot easier to
control social
media hell you could argue writers
didn't really have a voice to the public
at all nobody knew who the writers were
but social media gets you access to them
and some writers have been very prolific
in their use of social media and have
built followings and have built people
who are going to be already inherently
sympathizing with them and this stuff
gets p pass around so easily and as I
said despite the fact that the general
public doesn't control the outcome their
opinions do
matter
because if uh things go back into
negotiations and Studios can sit down
and they can say look you're making this
thing last stretch out so long the
Public's going to start resenting you
and maybe they won't want to see the
movies that you write or you star in
anymore at all
you you really think you can keep this
going they can't make a push like that
not when there is
quantifiable clear large scale
support for the writers for the actors
is it ubiquitous and Universal no no
literally nothing is but it's very
clear that the writers and the actors
are being supported over the studios
because before the voice of the actors
of the Unions would be one
representative doing the rounds on the
news usually the the president of sag
aftera so like in this case it would
have been Fran drer doing the rounds and
she'd probably be the only voice you
hear and she's recognizable she's known
she becomes the face of it and you think
to yourself just seeing her over and
over again well yeah but you get
residuals off the nanny you're probably
fine like if you're just fighting for
people like you maybe you are just being
reading and maybe the studios are right
but hers is not the only voice getting
out there voices of many a beloved actor
and even some more nich and character
actors but who still have loyal fan
bases you can have stuff go out there
like Denise Crosby putting out what her
residuals were looking like from Ray
Donovan which she appeared in multiple
episodes of and her residual check was
pathetic is she a massive big name most
people know no but people watch that
show know her people who watch Star Trek
know her her fans know her they see that
and they go what the
hell the public has
access to more than just the approved
corporate executive cleared narrative
and I really don't think they counted on
that I think that's very evidenced by
how the executives were talking about
the strikes early on how casually they
were prepared to say it's a necess Neary
evil to starve them out of their
homes and that has happened and the
thing is no matter how many news
headlines word the fact that Billy
Porter had to sell his house in such a
way as to maybe make it plausible to
think that it would be okay to blame the
strikers for it no matter how many
websites run headlines like that folks
can find out the man's actual words and
who he actually blames and it's not the
unions the ability to control the
narrative is gone and I really think the
studios did not realize
that they see social media as an
extension of their marketing arm at most
by and large I really don't think they
understand what a wild west it
is and like social media is messed up
and uh weirdly controlled weirdly
policed weirdly censored in various ways
that it it's different on every platform
uh it's either
you know controlled in certain ways or
it's too much of a free-for-all in which
case it may not honestly be safe to be
on depending on who you are so I'm not
trying to praise social media as our
Lord and
savior most social media uh apps sites
and companies can as far as I'm
concerned go themselves and yes I do say
that as someone whose living is
literally made on what is effectively a
long form video social media app but
regardless
there is still access to an audience
that used to be gate kept from people
who are just on the front
line and it's not
anymore and
audiences most of them aren't going to
blame the actors they're not going to
blame the writers and if they're not
blaming the actors and writers the
investors probably won't either even if
the executives try
to eventually the
investors are going to be swayed by
seeing people continuing to use the
hashtag continuing to donate to the
funds to help uh keep actors fed and
their families supported Link in the
description for that if you want to
help these things keep rolling now can
they do it
indefinitely probably not but neither
can the studios because each quarter
that goes by that they don't get to log
the kind of returns they were supposed
to have
cuz that's that's something to always
remember when it comes to projected
returns and
profits it doesn't matter if they made a
profit they set forth
projections a year ago for what they
said they could make and if they
don't the investors are not
happy and again there's a lot of
Hollywood accounting to try and fudge
that but you can only fudge so much and
you really can't fudge a lot when um
you're running out of
product and your shows aren't
running they weren't in a very strong
position going into this and I don't
think they realized the
strength of the union members and their
ability to reach an audience or to tap
the audience they had already built as
part of their own actual
careers all of that
is looking at the studios and going what
the hell's wrong with you what is it you
do you at the top what why are you paid
so much why are you paid more as one
person than it would cost the studio to
cover all of the demands of both the
writers and the actors why are you paid
more than
that now is this going to topple the
executive class no at a certain point
you get too rich to
lose at worst you just Plateau most of
them just fail upward infinitely forever
that's just a sad reality of capitalism
but uh I don't want to fall down that
hole too much so just know that in the
end while these Executives will remain
deeply overpaid at least for the time
being they uh can't just assume that
people go along
anymore that means the unions that means
the
audiences that does also mean the
investors at a certain
point deciding to fight the union is
costing you you more than it just would
have cost you to just do what they
asked it would have been so
simple and the quotes
dropped about the unions being
unrealistic and about starving them out
just showed how unprepared these
Executives were for the social media age
and some of these folks aren't entirely
unsavvy when it comes to social media
they still weren't
ready and I think it's going to be a
contributing factor for when they
ultimately
lose so there we
go my thoughts on one of the reasons or
at least uh from the perspective of the
studios and Executives the reason they
weren't expecting to be having such a
hard time and it's such a well- earned
hard
time enjoy it you deserve
it what are your thoughts on this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it patreon
pays my bills um by all means contribute
to the uh entertainment fund to help um
support those striking but you
know me too maybe if you got a buck or
so hanging around I I don't mean to harp
on that so much there links other things
in the description that I do check those
out don't worry too much about it what I
want you to
remember especially if you are on the
picket line you are
beautiful you are
valid you are
loved you are the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
[Music]
adjourned a special thanks to my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore look
fulla Tac the thing that goes doink in
the anime Ruth Oliver be solitary
pictures bog Melinda Walters Jen Auntie
Kate 808 Becky Sparks R I'll be lik the
poodle Robin Powell Tracy scrapit angry
caspero Adam RDL Taylor Dave Hall
Rosalyn B you'll see a bunch of other
names down there as well there's plenty
of things to get on the patreon and yeah
you can hear me attempt say your name
without embarrassing myself check out
the rewards and thank you for everyone
who supports
[Music]
this
oh